on Afghanistan the Pentagon is preparing  to withdraw troops from the country what  do we know about that decision David the  US military is willing to go from the  current level of 14,000 troops down to  about 8,500 as part of a initial peace  deal with the Taliban but here's the  important thing to understand about the  prospects for peace the Taliban want all  foreign troops out and the US military  is not willing to do that and the reason  is that Isis is also in Afghanistan and  the Pentagon says it needs to keep  troops there in order to go after Isis  which is still actively plotting  terrorist attacks against the United  States David Norton at the Pentagon  thanks